what if nezuko became a Demon Slayer
instead of tundra how strong would she
be would she be able to awaken Sun
breathing and most importantly would she
and her demon brother be able to take
revenge and defeat the demon lord muzon
well firstly she would try to carry
Tantra to a doctor since she doesn't yet
understand what happened to him she
would also encounter giyu and same as
her brother would persuade him not to
kill them nezuko would have the same
determination as Tundra wanting to get
revenge and stop demons at any cost
based on this we can assume that she'd
also Master the water breathing and
easily pass the final selection however
the first major difference would happen
when nezuko arrives in Tokyo contrary to
Tantra nezuko doesn't have an enhanced
sense of smell and therefore wouldn't
meet muzon at all since she didn't meet
muzon she also never fought susumaru and
yahaba and most importantly she never
met tomayo this may sound like it's not
a big deal but it will actually make
nezuko's Journey a lot harder this is
only one of the many ways that would be
different in this version of the story
and I bet you be very happy about one
change in particular anyway she'd
eventually team up with zenitsu and
enosuke during the tsutsumi Mansion R of
course zenitsu would instantly fall in
love with her nothing unusual here but
she would unfortunately only see him as
a friend Mount natagumo is the place
where things start to get pretty hard
for nezuko here she would have to fight
the lower rank 5 demon rui the fight
would go okay for nezuko at the
beginning but that would all change
suddenly when rui activates his enhanced
threats at this moment tantro remembered
the hinokami kagura dance his father
used to perform but would nezuko be able
to do the same well I don't think so
firstly she was younger than tantro at
that time and didn't pay much attention
to the hinukami kakura dance also her
father never talked to her about it and
instead gave all information along with
hanifuda earrings to tanjaro so how will
nezuko survive this attack well although
tanjaro is a demon now he still retains
some of his human memories if he senses
that his sister is in grave danger this
should push him to unlock all of these
memories and activate his hidden Powers
the obviously wouldn't be able to use
actual Sun breathing but he would
probably manage to adapt everything he
knows about kagura dance and come up
with a way to use it as a blood demon
art nezuko's determination and tantaro's
Newfound Powers should be enough for
them to defeat rui due to his knowledge
of the kagura dance Tundra would be a
much stronger demon than nezuko he would
easily be on a demon Moon level alright
since you guys are Demon Slayer fans I
take it you like beautiful anime
Graphics superpowers and amazing fights
with monsters if I'm right then you'll
definitely love path to Nowhere which is
the sponsor of today's video path to
Nowhere is an anime game with absolutely
stunning Graphics that features RPG
elements and gotcha mechanics it's
definitely not one of those childish
mobile games that you are used to seeing
it actually revolves around much darker
themes like crime prison and gangs you
play as a chief of Crisis control Bureau
and your job is to punish an endless
super-powered criminals to fight against
evil monsters these prisoners are known
as Sinners and each one of them has
unique abilities and Powers the
character design is also very cool and
each character is easily distinguishable
with semi-imposto Japanese art style if
you want to be really unique you can
also acquire additional attires for your
Sinners there are a bunch of Sinners you
can unlock but my favorite is Knox I
really like her design and she has this
huge sword that I can't wait to use in
battle the thing I like most about this
game is the strategy and tactical
thinking required to beat some of the
levels path to Nowhere is very
Innovative and has some special
mechanics that make it stand out for
example there are Elite enemy cores that
can only be destroyed with Sinner's
ultimate abilities download path to
Nowhere Now by clicking the link in the
description or by scanning the QR code
and once you're in the game you can
enter my special gift code that will
grant you some amazing gifts anyway
after this Tundra and nezuko would
eventually be accepted by the hashiras
and go on their next mission with
rengoku since the Demon Slayer Duo is
much stronger at this point than in the
original story mujin train Arc would
play out really differently after some
struggle nezuko and inosuke would be
able to defeat enmu and rangoku engages
akaza in one-on-one battle however one
thing that's different this time around
is that tantro is there to help him they
clearly wouldn't be able to defeat akaza
but at least they could survive together
until dawn this would mean that rengoku
would actually survive the incident and
would be able to help the hashiras in
all of their future battles come on guys
I literally saved when Goku from dying
that deserves at least a subscribe look
even rengoku agrees with me sometime
after this the main Trio would undertake
another mission this time in the
Entertainment District with tenjin the
fact that nezuko is a human will make
another huge difference in this Arc okay
so after they arrive at the district
they will encounter daki and guitaro the
upper ranked demons zenitsu enosuke and
nezuko would engage daki since she is a
weaker one while tenjin and Tundra would
engage guitero this fight would play out
pretty similar to the original story
with demon Slayers decapitating both
demons simultaneously so what's the
catch well after the fight inosuke
intention were grievously injured and
poisoned and who was the one who saved
them that's right it was nejuko with her
blood demon art this time the only demon
is tantro and his blood demon art is
come completely different unfortunately
this would mean that both inosuke and
tension would die during this Arc with
one of the main characters dying how
will the story continue would the Demon
Slayer still be able to win in the end
since inosuke wasn't a part of The
Swordsman Village Arc we can assume that
this Arc would play out pretty similar
to the original the only difference
would be that tanjaro would be the one
to gain immunity to the Sun instead of
nezuko this would make a lot of sense
considering that he already has
yunukamikakura powers and comes from a
lineage of sun-breathing users okay now
comes the most important part the
infinity Castle Arc and there are many
things that are different now firstly
rengoku is alive which is very good
enosuke intention are dead which is not
so good Anton Dro is a very strong demon
who can help a lot in the final battle
do you remember when I said that nezuku
not meeting Tamayo back in Tokyo would
make her journey much harder well it's
here that we'll see exactly why in the
original story Tundra collected blood
samples from strong demons and sent them
to Tamayo so she could create a medicine
that turns Demons back into humans with
these samples and shinobu's help tomayo
made this medicine which greatly helped
the Slayers fight against muzon however
nizuku never collected these samples and
therefore tamayo's drug will not be
fully ready by the time muzan arrives
alright so how would the final battle
play out muzan arrives and talks to
kagaya the house explodes and muzon is
injured tomayo arrives and injects him
with the drug although muzon is
incredibly weakened by its effects he
doesn't need to make a cocoon and
regenerate and can instead Engage The
Slayers immediately this is really
dangerous since Slayers would have to
fight both muzon and upper moons at the
same time can they manage to pull it off
Busan lets off a psychopathic laugh as
he pulls everyone into the infinity
Castle a calm voice of muzon rings
throughout the castle welcoming them to
his Abode welcome to your death you
lowly humans a world of demons is the
only true future suddenly the castle
begins to spin again and this time it
throws the hashiras in various
directions the final battle is about to
begin and it is clear that something of
an epic proportion is about to happen
and it won't end well for once side a
flock of low tier demons descends from
the top of the castle however it turns
out to be easy work for the pillars as
they slice through the weak demons with
various forms of their breathing Styles
at that moment with the last low tier
demon defeated the upper moons arrive
standing before their respective
opponents nezuko and her demon brother
are shocked to see none other than muzon
the Demon Lord standing right in front
of them muzan mocks them calling them
pathetic weaklings he looks at Tundra
especially licking his lips as the boy
he has been chasing for a while now is
finally within his grasp muzon launches
blood whips at Tundra but the boy is too
shocked to move physical Dives in at the
last moment pushing her brother away and
they both barely avoid the hit as the
ground breaks open from the impact of
the whip he laughs and says that was
only a warning and that the next time he
attacks he'll be much more serious
without any hesitation muzon sends a
barrage of whips at them they narrowly
manage to dodge the attack but not
without a few cuts and injuries we
barely started fighting and you're
already panting this is why I hate
Humanity your limitations are a curse
it's painful to even look at you you are
the one who is cursed your entire
existence is an abnormality that should
have never existed tantaro continues
from where she stopped we are here to
put an end to you and rid the world of
demons once and for all you can say
whatever you want but the only way this
ends is with me devouring you and
gaining immunity to sunlight I'll
finally become truly invincible and I'll
rule the world forever nizuko enraged
latches out at muzon attacking him with
water breathing tenth form constantly
box muzon refuses to block seeing it as
trivial however the water dragon appears
behind nezuko and the attack starts to
get stronger and stronger this leads to
an opening for tundra to jump in and
attack with his blood demon art Sun
Massacre fire shaped as multiple sharp
objects suddenly appears and seemingly
pierces through muzon he screams out in
shock but when the demon Slayers look
closer they realize that muzon has
blocked the attack and he only screams
to mock them is this the best you can do
so pathetic let me show you what a real
Attack looks like Luzon brings out his
whips again and by the time he is done
nizuku has lost her left arm while
tantro is on his knees as thick drops of
blood drop down all over the floor
around him muzon says to them nezuko you
should be on your knees like your
brother only that's appropriate for
someone who opposes me both of you are
weak and pathetic and now you will die
like all others before you you're right
as humans we are weak and fragile I know
that but one thing that we'll never do
is bow before someone like you nezuko's
words give tantro the much needed
strength to stand up and the siblings
form a stance the Demon Lord is annoyed
however notices something different
about nezuko he looks closer and notices
that she has awakened her Demon Slayer
Mark she Whispers a few things to Tantra
then screams it moves on saying my
brother and I have an unbreakable Bond
who can't possibly imagine the things
we've been through together I'll never
let you have him this is where we'll
finally stop you the siblings combine
their techniques nezuku's water
breathing and tanzuro's sunblood demon
art the attack is so powerful that it
makes cracks in the floor where they
were standing the combination of water
and fire techniques leads to a huge
smoke that greatly reduces muzon's
Vision all of a sudden they jump out
from the smoke behind muzon and cleanly
slash him across his body as soon as he
tries to counter the siblings have
already disappeared in the smoke again
they repeat this a few more times and
each time they land a perfect hit on a
seemingly helpless Demon Lord as the
smoke vanishes Tundra and nezuko can be
seen exhausted but hopeful as they
finally manage to deal some serious
damage to muzon they look up and the
Hope on their faces immediately
disappears when they see that muzan is
already completely healed you did well I
am quite impressed but unfortunately for
you I am not an average upper Moon demon
these attacks have no chance of harming
me this is the end of the road for you
moves on lunch is the strongest attack
yet and the siblings can only watch and
despair knowing they have no chance of
dodging it as death approaches them they
hear a soft voice water breathing 11th
form dead kong Kiyu arrived at the last
moment and deflected muzan's attack
saving the siblings The Demon King is
pissed but he's also shocked that guiyu
defeated one of his upper moons in
disbelief muzon looks at Kiyu and behind
him all the other hashira appear one by
one muzan cannot believe his eyes and
uses his senses to try and get in
contact with the upper moons but he
can't all of them have been defeated the
hashiras encourage tantro and nezuko to
stand up and help them one last time in
the final battle for Humanity everyone
vows to fight with everything they have
and stall moves on until dawn after a
long battle almost all the hishira can
be seen lying on the ground dead nezuko
tantro and guiyu are the only ones left
standing as the sun rises they jump
toward muzan and hold him with their
bare hands in complete Agony and
disbelief moves son screams as he
disintegrates defeated by the mere
humans he hated the most click on this
video where we explained what would
happen if rengoku accepted akaza's offer
to transform trust me you really need to
see this one